in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
[Music]
running is great too because it's very
good for your health it's good for your
body and it's good for your soul and for
your brain because running even makes
you more creative and that's what I'm
going to check out with you and as I
hope you're very creative you're a
runner and you want to talk with me
about running but the first thing I want
to know is and how often do we have to
run to get all those health effects this
is what our viewer gianmarco iberia from
Italy wants to know I think this highly
depends on where you come from if you
are starting completely new with boards
I think it's enough to start with one or
two trainings a week and if you're more
advanced you can do from two to three
trains a week but to be really healthy
you shouldn't exaggerate it just start
it slow and listen to your body and
starting slow I think it's one of the
key secrets Diego from Portugal tried to
take up running and he's getting out of
breath after five minutes I have to run
so what would you suggest I would
suggest to take it even slower than that
so maybe just start with walking go for
a walk for 10 minutes 20 minutes then go
to 30 or 60 minutes and then you can
start with running and they're the same
procedure M stance low and start short
and then make it bigger so it's like an
interval training and but not with
running and running very fast running
very slow but with walking and running
this is what you can do a little later
but first of all I would I would start
with just walking just walk for 30
minutes or 60 minutes so how do you
breathe properly when you run you need
to have a good rhythm okay so you need
to start with a rhythm that matches to
your feet so if you are running a little
faster you need to adjust this you need
to breathe faster and if you don't do
this you will get some side stitches and
this is what you need to avoid so rhythm
is everything and if you go faster
adjust the rhythm to your pace it
doesn't come naturally I mean if I run
faster I will be faster as well yeah you
will breathe faster as well and you
breathe more deeply but you need to
adapt this to your right into your
running pace and you need to focus on
this so you really need to concentrate
on keeping your rhythm
with the breathing you might think that
running is very easy because we all run
since we were children
but as we just saw in the report the
ladies in the park had to train for the
run so do you train for running as well
yeah I prepared for every run and there
are some exercises that you can do
before everyone to prepare the joints
the muscles and the technique and the
technique is one of the most important
thing that people tend to forget so we
need to refocus on this and this is what
I do before everyone and this is called
the running a bzees and this is what
Jonas is going to show us now yes sir
we'll all right so what are those
exercises the first exercise is focusing
on your ankle okay and this is the
starting position okay place your toe on
the ground right and then you roll it
down on your here okay I'll try body
position yeah arms up okay and then just
like this okay and we go forward okay
but I mean this is not my usual running
posture here I'm not skipping around on
my forefoot why do you have to train
this we do this because we are dividing
the running technique into four
exercises okay and this one is focusing
on your anchor the muscles around your
anchor or and this is what we are
training now good fair enough
next exercise are the knee raises up to
90 degrees okay same as for every
exercise upright upper body position
knees up and then we go forward
tell you the last exercise the last
exercise is the butt kick so you bring
your heel next your butt okay and you
try not to raise the knee now so this is
the movement up right upper body
position and there we go
a frequent runner problem is the so
called shin splint syndrome
what's that the shrimp Lin syndrome is a
pain that you can have on the front of
your tibia can be very painful and is
usually caused by overload and running
too much or too hard or too fast after a
long period of not working out sometimes
it comes for advanced runners as well so
they just train for a marathon and they
do a lot of volume training over the
week and then it causes the pain and the
tibia another reason can be that you do
not have the right shoe that fits your
biomechanics for the foot and that
changes some of these mechanics and
another problem can be that you are a
heel strike runner and this is a
technical problem that can cause the
syndrome as well how do you prevent it
by new shoes you need to have the right
shoes for the ground that you're running
on and you need to take it slow if you
are having a break and then starting
again with working out and running you
need to take it slow you need to listen
to your body because these passive
structures just need more time to adapt
to the running another reason is that
you just try to change the technique a
little bit to be more of a forefoot
striker and not so much of a heel
striker but I mean Ronnie is sometimes
painful which is normal but when do I
have to see a doctor you need to see a
doctor when it's pain that it's not
muscle related so if you have maybe a
pain in your knees or on your TBR on any
other plastic structure you need to go
to a doctor having sore muscles after a
long run there's normal but you need to
listen to your body and you need to
listen to it and react it what about
overweight people if you're B's is it
okay for you to run or should you just
avoid running all together I would not
recommend to go for a run because it's
too much pressure and low that you put
on your joints I would recommend to use
a more joint friendly sport like
swimming or cycling or go to the gym and
have the workout for your muscles but
would not recommend to go for run and
after you lost the weight you can only
go for it so I guess that many of our
viewers now would like to go outside and
go for a run and it says something they
should do before if they just start a
new sport always recommend to go to a
doctor and have a check-up on everything
on joints on general health on the heart
because you can have a problem and you
do not know about this and this is what
you should go for doctor for
[Music]
you